we don't think you should own coin made
in china i said the only way i can
possibly
not own kind of china coin is to make it
myself so
new game plan every coin i'm going to
own i'm going to know
where it came from when it was created
and it's going to be virgin to me my
wallet will be packed
of completely compliant coin
i'm gonna make you famous on my youtube
channel get over here i heard a row back
first of all you like the hat yeah look
at this head i think it's gonna look
fantastic on you
that is beautiful isn't it beautiful
it's yours it's yours
you gotta
right there spectacular spectacular that
looks
absolutely gorgeous i know you look
pretty good mom
can i keep both of them yeah only one
look at this it looks spectacular
his and hers who knew happy wife is a
happy life
another happy customer just make
everybody happy here on the beach today
it's row back madness hey everybody
great to be back for a new episode of
ask mr wonderful where from miami beach
anyways what i want to talk about um
this week is what happened to me on this
whole issue around bitcoin
now bitcoin has been in the news like
crazy hitting new highs past a trillion
dollars of market cap
or aum it's just really big and you have
to kind of make up your own mind
do you believe in it or not so that's
sort of binary yes no
now i bought some bitcoin and ethereum
back in 2017 so i've seen what's
happened to it since then but i never
got to talk about it because the
regulators and i'm involved in many
other
financial services industries like etfs
and payment systems and
highly regulated businesses and the
regulators were not on board for talking
about
bitcoin talking about coins talking
about this as an asset class
because they hadn't made up their minds
on it yet and then recently just in the
last few
months really regulators in switzerland
in france in uk
in canada in new zealand oh there's my
lemonade
thank you so much that's great
that's good lemonade anyways the point
is
the regulators have been changing their
minds
take canada for example the regulator
there has allowed for etfs there's
bitcoin
exchange traded funds i think there's
three of them now two more coming
there's a lot of activity going on
regarding this asset class where people
can buy it just like they can in a
basket of stocks and
exchange traded fund same things
happening in switzerland and france etc
etc so
so basically it hasn't happened yet
stateside but it looks like the
regulator is going to open up slowly to
this idea
of you know bitcoin becoming a real
asset class now i think it's more like a
property
so i came out sort of came out as really
a good term for it
and said look i'm going to do an
allocation of three percent of my
portfolio
in bitcoin oh that's good lemonade
you're so hot out here you gotta hydrate
and
so at the same time when you think about
it if it's three percent waiting
i didn't think much about it until the
phone started ringing the texts were
howling at me i got all these emails
from institutional clients that i deal
with
and they said wait a second where is
this coin you're buying coming from
i said who cares where it comes from
well you know the majority of coin is
mined in china
yeah the same place that's under
sanction from the united states the
chinese miners burn
coal they pollute to create electricity
they're very inefficient in some cases
and they make bitcoin by
burning coal which is horrific if you're
if you care about sustainability and
many of these institutions have
sustainable
uh you know committees and they can't do
this kind of thing
so i also want to stay on the side of
compliance i want to i do
i do not want to buy coin from polluters
i do not want to buy coin from china or
any other country that's under sanction
i don't want to do that so new game plan
here's what i decided to do and i came
out and talked about this too
i said look in the case of bitcoin
every single coin has a time it was
created
so you know exactly the moment it became
a bitcoin
but you don't know where it was created
you know the founding algorithms never
contemplated that being an issue
and it is an issue because i don't want
to own china coin nor are many
institutions not want to own china coin
so the only way to avoid that is to make
your own
virgin coin become a minor yourself so
new game plan for me
wait a little hydration break here
little lemonade
very tasty you know i just thought of
something i think you might like this
what is a drink on the beach without a
little umbrella
you gotta have a little umbrella look at
that isn't that cute
i could put it in my drink you know
stick it in one of the limes
or just for the floral display of it i
think this looks terrific
here's what i'm thinking oh yeah that
looks good
it's kind of got a hawaiian vibe to it
anyways so
i start getting a ton of calls from
institutions saying where'd the coin
come from and i said look
i understand there's an issue you know
because i work with them every day
they said we don't think you should own
coin made in china i said the only way i
can possibly
not own kind of china coin is to make it
myself so
new game plan i started calling bitcoin
miners all around the world
i said look you need capital you want to
expand your operations you need
technology you need money to make more
coin in a more efficient
manner and burn less electricity to do
that
i'm willing to finance you in exchange
for a royalty i want you to pay me back
in virgin coin right that's a good game
plan
that's exactly what i did so here's the
plan in denmark
in sweden in other countries that are
compliant northern canada where they pay
less to air condition the servers
because it's very cold outside
more efficiency more productivity and
more compliance and sustainability
that's my mode now every coin i'm going
to own i'm going to know
where it came from when it was created
and it's going to be virgin to me my
wallet would be packed of completely
compliant coin not blood coin
not coin from china not coin from
countries
that are abusing human beings not coined
from countries that are burning too much
electricity
and wasting to make their coin i want
efficiency i want compliance
and guess what many many institutions
want the same thing so they saw
they started calling me up saying look
why can't we partner together why don't
we do this together why don't we create
minds you will put capital up beside you
we'll be paid in royalties as well
i think it's a great model but i guess
the big news of the week is
there are many people that really care
where their coin comes from
and how it was made and that is done
sustainably
and i think that's fantastic news and
think about sustainability as a theme
because everything i invest in now
that's what i care about i want to know
that it's being done efficiently and
sustainably
that's how you pass the world onto
someone the next generation knowing you
did your piece
you did your part if you like that video
wait did you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe it's you know money for
nothing and chicks for free for the next
three months they're pouring money into
the american economy like they've never
done
this new 1400 check plus another 400
that goes straight
into people's pockets and in many cases
into the market